okay I'm gonna predict an English which
is to open up with the sea porn okay and
I'll go E4 okay uh we'll mix it up and
I've only played okay
I've only played a ventric once over the
board in 2009 and I remember preparing
for him I spent four hours trying to
predict his opening and
he plays something he's never played
before so
um yeah he plays every opening Under the
Sun and he knows them really well he
knows all the ideas
um yeah and look at those books behind
him I just I just love the way we're
talking about the old books those books
looks ancient whatever really old chest
books just sitting behind him there 53
year old vasil ivanchok in his very
first tournament in meltwater Champions
chess tour against uh a player 36 years
younger than him pregnant moves are
coming out what kind of an opening are
we looking at yeah so it's the Spanish
opening and it's a branch of the Spanish
opening we call the arc angel and that
means Black's uh kind of bringing out
his Bishop early this is a very
ambitious choice of square for Black's
Bishop this last move Black's Bishop of
course is on a great diagram now but
it's likely to get hit and once the
white Pawn starts stepping forward first
on the edge of the board and then maybe
later in the center we'll see uh if
antrik decide how direct he wants to be
Black's Rook now just getting out of the
way uh the a file is about to become
open potentially and this is all very
standard stuff I think this is a decent
Choice by Prague but Adventure clearly
has a lot of experience here this
opening has been around for many many
years there's been a lot of recent
developments however and Evancho decides
to put his Knight on the edge of the
board
Target is the B5 Square the B5 Pawn
and okay black castles this does involve
a temporary Pawn sacrifice there we go
white winter Pawn but black creates a
pin and I remember playing through these
lines when I was young when I was
younger than Prague even and I was just
so confused it was uh very difficult to
evaluate the positions because often
black stays are pouring down for a long
time but he does have very active pieces
yeah what do you guys think decent
opening choice
I'm surprised by this opening choice you
know it's a Courageous one because of
course you know you are you are gameting
upon it's the sharpest possible response
to opening up with the King's Pawn and
uh this is the reason why it's so sharp
because now take a look at why it's king
it's totally open and uh practice he's
not uh he's not pulling any punches here
because look at he's going straight for
the king and we are probably still in
mainstream Theory because I'm just
checking the database yep lots of games
been played before yeah and uh just a
few years ago there were some opening
books um some kind of opening works on
this exact position on this line and as
far as I remember computers thought that
this is just all a four-straw but black
has to know his stuff black has to know
a lot of uh a lot of tricks later and we
see the players both over 60 Minutes
they've gained time from when they
started the game that's because they're
so confident
and they've clearly studied this Prague
was just looking off to the side there
he knows what to do he brings his Queen
out
very near the white king looks a bit
scary if you're new to this position
that white king is about to get attacked
by The Black Queen and Knight
but at the moment no direct threats I'm
expecting white to just capture a pawn
in the center
at some point White's King will try and
find safety just in the corner it will
Shuffle across one square to the light
Square
and everything to play for any
predictions at this early stage yeah I
mean I think it's pretty well known to
position you can see the the speed
they're moving at as well I mean it's
already move uh I can't see on my screen
but it's getting into the game with the
15.
um I mean you have to be a bit careful I
think with both sides don't you in this
kind of structure because white is
pulling up so black needs to prove the
compensation but White's King is very
weak and the Queen and Knight which are
just hovering around the white king they
work really well together those two
pieces so you've got to you've got to be
very careful of the third black piece is
opened up I'd be very very scared let's
say the back black Bishop if that can
open up on the diagonal or if a black
Rook well I love the swingers don't I'm
always going on about the swingers if a
rook can swing around something like
that I'd be very scared but it's saying
all that I'm assuming uh they both know
what they're doing Chucky now slowing
down a little bit so could he be out of
theory now possibly possibly because I'm
just checking this database and there's
only six games but the position is so
sharp that I find it difficult to
believe that both players have not
looked at this before and I have to say
the stats are in White's favor sorry not
White's favor Black's favor as you can
imagine because white is playing with
fire here yeah no matter what the
computer says as well I mean the stakes
are higher for weight as you mentioned
avanka if you make one bad move with
white you probably just get checkmated
if you make one bad move with Black
maybe you're just a pawn down and you'll
live to fight another day
so we'll see what Prague has up his
sleeve now he looks very energetic this
is the difference between the
generations the older generation you see
more stoic vanchook okay he's got
certain mannerisms but in general he'd
just be thinking focusing Prague needs
that adrenaline yeah yeah it's
interesting really fascinating position
and David you mentioned having something
up your sleeve well we have the coolest
surprise for everyone which we will We
Will Reveal at the end of the show but
in order to reveal it we do need your
help so we're asking you to send us your
coolest pictures and you can do that
using the hashtag chess Champs and we'll
feature them on the show with a surprise
which I cannot wait I know to reveal it
to you guys because it is seriously
amazing it is such a cool surprise so we
need you guys to share your best chess
pictures it could be a selfie you take
today watching the show or maybe playing
some chess it can be something you have
in your or archive playing maybe your
favorite tournament playing the first
game ever someone else playing chess I
don't know but share your picture is on
Twitter
oh I'm looking forward to that surprise
yeah
I think we could have many surprises
this tournament
and off the board yeah
it's uh meanwhile prank now thinking and
maybe we can dive a bit deeper see what
is going through the young Prodigy's
mind because there's definitely a lot of
pieces so left the board already yeah a
lot of pieces are left the board but if
we if we kind of focus on what's left on
the board I mean this queen this night
very near this white king and the white
king doesn't have any Defenders as Simon
mentioned
um so Prague he wants to bring a third
piece into the attack that's something I
learned from Ivanka three is the magic
number when it comes to attacking pieces
so you need to get this piece in somehow
or this piece but they're both blocked
by White's Pawn Center maybe he's also
thinking at some point of trying to get
this rook in the game you can do that as
Simon mentioned by kind of lifting it
and Swinging it across but it takes a
few moves a bit slow there maybe you
could kind of push a pawn forward at
some point to open up a line for this
Rook
that's so much to calculate you could
also decide when to flick in a capture
of Pawns in the center I'm not sure who
this favors this kind of uh Trader pawns
these these guys look very strong but
they are potential targets for the black
pieces
uh what else could black be thinking
about here maybe just moving his Rook
across putting some pressure on the
center is there any chance that black
could try to do something with that
loose night setting
yeah
um definitely a possibility there are
some other branches of this opening
where you can get away with certain
tricks against this piece at some point
but I don't really see how at the moment
I guess you could take this Pawn with a
bishop for example opening up an attack
against the White Knight but
the White Knight just Retreats and
captures then we see just a trade and
again it's not clear the Knight and
Bishop have disappeared from these two
squares
but who does that favor long term the
white Bishops are very good here but
short term still a bit loose for white
Simon I think you take the black pieces
from here in this uh in this position
attacking chances yeah I mean I I guess
nowadays positions like this are very
very well analyzed in general I know
they both are slowing down they might be
out of theory but you've got to play
into positions which you enjoy playing
this is like a key thing I think a lot
of people forget so do you like holding
on to the extra Pawn defending a bit uh
trying to soak up the pressure if so you
take white or do you like risking
playing sacrificial getting the
initiative and trying to keep that
initiative going I mean both both Styles
have big dangers but personally I I love
attacking so the white king is weaker
blacks pieces slightly more scarier so I
take black here I think it's actually a
very clever opening choice in back from
Prague because if you think about
opening knowledge how we learn nowadays
computers is how you learn like really
you know and Prague I imagine his
capacity of quickly absorbing opening
information is much higher than Chucky's
you know Chucky might still be relying
on books or old analysis so why not take
him into something very very sharp where
uh your opening knowledge can shine a
little bit more but saying that I I
don't know what mood to play I mean I
guess if I was black I'd think about
taking the pawn in the middle moving a
rook over I think it's really key to uh
you know keep the pressure on and try to
get another piece in but you know White
Center looks extremely powerful uh here
as well and you know I want to try to
get the other night in the game with
this with this idea and try to swing the
Knight all the way to the king side as
David's showing here is is the kind of
thing I'd I'd be I need to get that
third piece in to to improve the
position so all these ideas I'd I'd be
going for checkmate ends the game go for
the king Checkmate that's all you need
easy easy Prague just do it simple take
them down so we've kind of shown a plan
for black I come in for surely white is
also going to play as well
you won't do anything you just let he
just let Chucky no Chucky Chucky Chucky
yeah okay in the video we saw uh Planet
Chucky he did actually Checkmate Magnus
Crossing they wouldn't choke it in uh
was it a blitz we're all Blitz game I
think yeah he's beaten Magnus several
times actually
um in all forms of jazz classical rapid
amblets
uh yeah I see I mean former we saw
actually him receiving the gold medal I
think in the world rapid Championship
former uh world champion there fan trick
so this format rapid chess is it the
perfect format for forever I'm not sure
because you know Evancho also has a
tendency to lose on time we've seen this
happen several times you know he gets so
absorbed into the position and kind of
just analyzing out all those intricacies
that he just forgets the clock and we
did see situations in the past where you
just let the clock ran out and uh we
were all saying I remember Simon and me
at one point we just can't move move and
he didn't move and we were like no way
uh but that was that was life and uh
well fragonanda has actually played a
move that was on my radar as well Bishop
takes porn I kind of like what you guys
were suggesting you know which was a bit
more harmonious here pregnant means
business and he's going directly for the
kill yeah I started some tactics as we
mentioned if this bishop is captured by
the white porn then White's night will
drop off to the Black Brook so uh White
also has the option of taking this
bishop with his own Knight he missed
that Checkmate idea there didn't he he's
big mistake could have finished the game
off there with that Knight coming over
less sharp than you today so less
aggressive
too much respect for the great Ivanka I
guess perhaps I think he still has uh
some tricks up his sleeve yeah some
definitely some uh slide plans and uh
okay meanwhile the White Knight does
step back indeed and capture we'll see
this white knight captured as well by
the black porn what else could you be
thinking about maybe he's thinking of
moving the black rock across but no why
not take that piece while it was sitting
there ready to be captured yeah you're
right Ivanka in 2013 the London um the
candidates tournament Evancho he lost on
time what was it three or four times wow
three or four games and that was of
course the famous event where Magnus
qualified on tie break with kramnik
Magnus actually uh yeah he owes a lot to
evantric because in the final round
evantric beat kramnik uh if permanent
could just go to draw kramnik would have
qualified for the world championship and
history would have been very different
so yeah
has made history what it is today yeah
exactly as and incidentally in that
tournament the round before Ivan Turk
actually beat Magnus wow
and you know Magnus is like oh my
goodness me how can you do this and then
of course in the final game he saved him
he's saved him Angel and Demon all at
once but it's never been world champion
himself evanchook but I heard people you
guys even said it maybe the best player
to never become world champion and he
was world number two many times and you
know he's incredibly strong and just
look at the focus that he's displaying I
mean he's world number two behind uh
Kasparov and wow this is when Kasparov
was just crushing absolutely everyone if
Kasparov wasn't around he would have
been world champion but it was a famous
case and one of my favorite games where
ivankuk I think got through to the
semi-final or very up there the world
championship qualifier and he's playing
your support famous now uh trainer and
they got down to tiebreak game and uh
Evancho lost this tiebreak game and had
he won that tight you know history may
have well been different because this
was in the 90s when he's really strong
but it it was it was a famous story it
was played in quite a busy City and um
as soon as he lost he he went out into
the busy street and he just started
screaming and uh just because it you
know this is this is his chance and you
know just in the street you're just
letting out all this emotion into the
street after the game so uh
um That's How The Story Goes I think you
know but it was it was a brilliant game
for anyone you know that your support
played to to win that match heartbreak
for everyone shook okay so he's playing
faster in this game he is playing fast
tonight I was just looking at uh his
camera I mean he's also muttering
something any any one of us good lip
readers anyone has it a guess not in
Ukrainian
we could have fun here who knows what
language language it is maybe there's a
different language on planet Chucky but
yeah a few moments ago what he kind of
while you were telling that story Simon
he closed his eyes as if he was reliving
that moment just kind of closing his
eyes talking to himself it's very much
uh it's kind of reminiscent of the
Queen's Gambit when Beth is staring at
the ceiling there's something going on
in his head that we wish we could see
yeah but you know he reminds me of I
mean like okay who does Chucky or my job
and this is a good question for the
audience as well if you can think of one
person in the whole world I mean for me
it's Spock out of uh out of Star Wars it
kind of reminds me of another genius
Star Trek even sorry yeah you know the
genius guy who it was you know that
calculator you could you know really
work magic there because he's got he's
got that same you know again like you
say he looks at the ceiling he he sort
of sees he sees these Amazing Ideas
which no one else does
um and yeah there's something very
special about that so yeah it also maybe
he looks like him as well sadly yeah
that's what I was thinking yeah he's
like little little bit
with uh [ __ ] say yeah the Vulcan race
as well yeah it's some 3D chess yeah
yeah the 3D chess yeah which just looks
really weird chess is hard enough and
look at Adventure now he's going through
so many emotions he's also wearing a is
that a real Madrid top oh yeah uh big
sports fan uh evanchook I should mention
the two most experienced players in this
tournament they've both got these kind
of mannerisms as well if Andrew collects
to twirl his eyebrows yeah and
girlfriend likes to 12 chess pieces
they're both famous for what do you
think he Twirls online because when he's
when he's playing over the board
girlfriend does twist the piece like
this but when he's playing online what
does he dwell
yeah look at Anita have a look so
playing with his Mouse just kind of
check under it he can
yeah I mean well there's one new move on
the board so after a couple of exchanges
Black's Rook has jumped into the white
Camp into the white half
hacking White's Pawn Center that's why
White's Bishop has developed the start
score Bishop protecting the Pawns in the
center but now if pregnantanda wants to
restore the material balance he can use
his rook and grab that white Pawn on B2
it's undefended now I'm not sure you
really want to move your Rook again if
white gets time to kind of bring pieces
towards the um uh the protection of his
King if the White Queen can develop if
White's Central pawns can push forward
if antrik just has a beautiful position
so Prague will he just uh kind of go for
that materialistic approach just grab a
pawn it's equal pawns the game goes on
or does he try to look for something a
bit more aggressive I suspect he might
be doing a hit and run with the Knights
he's actually going to capture the pawn
I haven't worked out the tactics here
I reckon he might just go for it and
initiate that fire on the board because
like you say you know he does can't be
messing around with the Rook uh make use
of those lines I say
oh yeah and uh this pin now means that
White's Bishop is likely to fall in the
center of the board so you've given up a
knight but this piece is now attacked by
both of the black Brooks and it's not
clear how you save it it feels a bit
shaky because Black's back rank is weak
Black's King if it's given a check on
the back rank it will be trapped There's
No Escape squares but it's hard to get
at it at the moment is there a Planet
Chucky move there this is where
we need that moment of Genius that
inspiration that Jackie always seems to
have I'm not sure if we can trust the
evaluation bar by the way at the moment
as well I'm not sure if that's moved so
I think it seems like it's been on point
four for a while so I don't know maybe
where would you place it I'm not well
I'm not sure I mean it's really it's a
very tactical position why it's got all
the sort of positional
um pluses at the moment two Bishops Pawn
Center extra porn but Black's got all
the Tactical chances so I I think in
like you know four or five moves we will
know
um a much more valid assessment of
what's what's happening here but this
Knight takes D4 is certainly a key move
isn't it I mean if this works and black
could be could be doing very well yeah
but I kind of feel there might be
something there I don't know what but
I'm thinking maybe you can go a bit
weird and move the Rook up and to okay
we've actually seen a different move
yeah so you think you're thinking maybe
something like this yeah this would be
very very complicated Prague decides to
go the kind of simple approach
materialistic I called it earlier but it
makes sense you put your Rook on a very
nice active Square you take a pawn back
and uh yeah it's it doesn't look
beautiful as you guys mentioned these
two Bishops they do look quite well
placed the pawn Center but what next for
white I just want to kind of over
protect the white king at some point the
queen is tied down I would love to
eventually bring her to this Square not
right now maybe The Rook can just slide
across one square
it's kind of I think you can never trap
The Black Queen but you can hint for
example that you'll attack her with the
bishop or with the Rook
um at least now with the white Rook on
this Square I feel a bit safer Okay
Chucky does go for that very sensible
and again the question for Prague is
what next how does he justify the kind
of temporary activity of his pieces
before white gets organized
not so easy anymore no not easy at all
and I was just going to highlight one
thing that is on the board that Magnus
really loves he loves those adjacent
power of Bishops just look at them on
those diagonals next to each other
beautiful if they ever open up because
start to attack the black king so yeah
the Bishops have all the potential it's
all about uh what black can do in the
short term yeah all right well it seems
to be a slow start to the Julius bear
generation cup look at the bars at the
bottom of the screen most of them
roughly to the middle except for in the
first game for Magnus Carlsen he is
playing that Indian Super Talent Arjun
Eric I see on the bars all the way over
to magnus's side with the black pieces
after only 20 minutes in that game so is
it gonna be an explosive start to the
tournament for Magnus who often has a
slow start to the tournaments or maybe
starting off with a win here today
I I it's a bit worried though because I
just had a look and Magnus is playing
the same opening that he played against
me on Friday night
Friday twice yeah really what did yeah
how do you go oh well let's just say I
was clearly winning both games of course
I will stop there
yeah just leave it quickly move on
you're a fast artist yeah just a slow
finisher no he he crushed me at the end
yeah I wouldn't say crushed I was uh
lucky enough to be watching convincing
that game and Simon was on the brink of
winning both of them but well it was
yeah unfortunately of course it's a bit
of a tricky customer isn't he he's yeah
he's very good at swindling his way out
of trouble what's this bullet chess or
Blitz it was Blitz three minutes so yeah
so so we had time to you know drink
coffee as well what a way to warm up to
commentating on the tournament uh Simon
yeah I mean beating the world champion
yeah well it would have been great and
uh obviously you've got this great chess
Pub in Norway yeah the good nights which
is uh one of the only ones in in the
world which is yeah a fantastic venue as
well and and speaking of the good night
next Saturday on the first day of of the
final in this tournament Hyman will be
at the good night there is going to be a
meet-up watch party chess event at the
good night so if you are in Oslo uh keep
your eyes up for that event we'll talk
some more about it we do have a move the
queen is moving yeah the queen is moving
and she's slightly closer to the white
king there's potential now uh that as
soon as the White Queen is distracted
the black Queen's going to jump in with
some checks on the diagonal that's the
only way the white king is vulnerable
right now on the light Square diagonal
also it's not possible to attack the
black queen anymore I mentioned a couple
of ways white was trying to do that
maybe with a rook or Bishop now the
black queen is relatively safe you can't
attack her because the Black Knight
covers some key squares so this is the
type of move that I love in Blitz chess
it's just it's not clear what it
actually does but it's annoying for the
opponent
it's kind of you stick something just in
their face the queen now is just sitting
right there next to your king and trying
to scare your opponent and Bluff some
tricks but look at him what's going
through that mind he doesn't want to
look at the queen I mean the first thing
that jumps to my mind is to line a rook
up against that Queen which is quite a
subtle little move I'm trying to trying
to think what a van would think like
then I'm thinking I think about it it's
just like I can't get into Chucky's mind
here we can keep an eye on Chucky just
uh I want to keep an eye on those facial
expressions but your idea Simon bringing
the Rook up two squares hinting
discovered attack against this queen I'm
hinting at some Bishop long bishop move
with you know you like said discovered
attack there something like that could
be logical but I'm I'm kind of also that
last move from Prague may be a good move
but I'm thinking if you have to play a
move like this which doesn't create any
threats it doesn't it just sort of is a
lurker I'd say
um I'm starting to really like White's
position I mean okay white has given his
Pawn Advantage away but he's got the
center he's got the two Bishops he's got
an open line I think it could be white
who ends up attacking the black king so
uh that that'd be my gut gut reaction
here that white should be comfortable
here maybe you can even bring the light
Square Bishop around to defend as many
many sort of ideas that you can you can
go for here really I guess I mean you
know if you think I mean would you take
white or black uh White every time I
mean I just rethink that White's
position is pretty safe I mean okay you
need to keep an eye on the king but
that's about it and I was thinking of
moving the bishop maybe even attacking
the Knight and then try to be cynical
about things and moving the rooked and
open line and trading of Queens
you're going to kill yourself
probably a very good idea because you've
got all the positional advantages why
not simplify the game and uh yeah I just
yeah I mean
opposite approach to me but a good
approach so yeah definitely I guess once
the coins are off it's an end game and
White's King is never in danger makes
sense probably a very very good plan
yeah
so uh yeah what is Chucky going to do is
he going to play one of these moves
we're expecting and look the bar
suddenly oh okay it's gone up in White's
over I think it's been stuck and they've
just fixed it that's all I think it's
happened yeah and we see the analysis
board here where I'm drawing some arrows
but actually I was going to say on the
game board suddenly pieces just changed
that we suddenly saw nights we suddenly
saw a bunch of other pieces but uh okay
White's Bishop does indeed come yeah
this is one of your ideas Simon just to
nudge this queen away the queen is
actually stuck defending her Knight so
you have to be a bit careful would you
say monster is winning this game yeah
it's possible well I mean now we can see
the bar
I wasn't sure before but yeah I reckon
I'm gonna say is that clearly winning I
mean I think there's still a lot of
scope to go wrong and uh of course it's
just two humans playing but yeah it's
looking really good you know he's got
everything he wants he's got the Santa
he's got the bishop pair he's got those
open lines for the Rooks he's it was
just a dream uh I just can't stop
admiring his position we talk about
controlling the center in chess look at
what white has done with his uh
formation there it's just kind of
everything protected everything
controlled is perfect and a big threat
so again if black does nothing if black
just moves the king uh to the side then
this bishop move is really stretching
Black's defenses the queen is attacked
remember the queen has to stay defending
her Knight on the edge of the board so
she has to step back one square White's
Rook will now probably Step Up
um there are also ideas of sliding the
queen across later on kind of with a
double attack maybe this was a threat in
the position as well but yeah once the
queen is kicked out of the white half of
the board it's all about white and the
ventric looks very happy with himself
right now after this bishop move yeah I
love this threat and actually this
secondary threat that uh might appear on
the board maybe over the next few moves
a double attack here and in the night
yeah it's looking good for Evancho and
we do have the first result in the
tournament Hans Neiman winning his first
game here and it is against the oldest
player in the tournament Boris galfonso
Hans Neiman takes the lead in the
tournament he could be joined by Ivan
shook by Magnus Carlson looking good for
him as well and he wants your care
Fighting For the Win I don't think
Prague looks too worried though
if there are still fighting chances this
is the prax temperament you know when
he's winning he doesn't look like he's
winning when he's losing look at him he
no emotion whatsoever I mean uh hang on
I say that and he's kind of giving the
game away a little bit that he's not
entirely happy with his position because
he breathed a big sigh but you know it's
just a mock of a great chess player you
know he's able to keep calm in those
situations of stress and uh
this is a very stressful situation I
have to say for pregnant because he's
fighting he is fighting for his life
here
in terms of chess
and it's just all a bit loose suddenly
like black species they look for
reactives the queen The Rook the two
knights but they're not really defended
and if just if something goes wrong if
the coordination between those pieces is
broken
she knows it's one of those nights I
could just look at Chucky just put the
video up at full screen bit you know
classical music in the back no no I mean
look at it it's it's such a interesting
character to look at isn't he I mean
like as you said David maybe he he was
saying something and then he's clinching
his eyes I mean uh you know he goes
through all the all the emotions here uh
but you're right David just Black's
position is very stretched here and um
you know there's The Rook move coming up
maybe there's lots of tempting moves
here isn't there yeah um and yeah
Adventure is well in control yeah we do
have to mention that Prague does have a
threat with this queen Retreat he is
threatening to capture the pawn in the
middle of the board with a check and uh
well prag sorry Adventure capacity to
take measures against that unfortunately
well fortunately for him I should say
it's very simple you know just move the
Rook up attack the queen kick her away
yeah you could even meet the queen and
couldn't you as well get another piece
near the black king and it it certainly
seems to me that the black king could
would be under a lot of pressure very
shortly yeah and this is interesting
just this battle of generations because
Prague has grown up kind of facing the
generation just above him the magnus's
uh I mean in this tournament we see I
mean a bunch of players the dudas the
gearies that's kind of generation just
above Prague but the older generation
they have a different style right and uh
they're very principled Evancho he I
mean we would think he'd be rusty he's
barely played over the board lately but
he's very principled he'll still play
what he thinks of the correct openings
he'll still have no fear he'll still uh
he's happy to weaken his King as long as
he gets those long-term advantages it's
a very different type of chess
interesting to see how Prague does
against that yeah old versus new I mean
this is this is why you know such an
exciting tournament uh this generation
gap that we we have here is going to be
fascinating to see how you know I think
we're all kind of rooting for the older
players aren't we I I'm gonna you know
I'm gonna say I am I want to see the old
guys do well because I'm I'm now be one
of the old guys
yeah they've got loads of Thomas to come
in the old players you know we grew up
on their games as David said earlier we
we grew up on their their brilliances
their you know their their you know
evangelics had some great games beating
Kasparov gelfand positional Mastermind
you know they are legends of the game
and it's huge inspiration right if if
these players uh 53 and 54 years old can
really make a mark in this tournament
yeah it just several times exactly like
you say you know that absolutely anyone
can do this that uh anyone can compete
at the top
um I am slightly concerned having said
all that about uh
nothing is um clock time because now the
first time he's gone under the clock and
he he I'm just reading it I mean what
can I say from his Expressions it looks
like he's in he's in pain
anyone else would be in pain with that
face but uh no I think he's just
calculating it okay and uh the genius
isn't it of uh you know you know that
genius is very they say a lot of pain
Geniuses you know and he is kind of the
pain genius but okay the evaluation
Bar's gone down a lot I mean there was
some other very tempting moves like I
also noticed he could have moved the
other Rook up but uh we should have been
you know again trying to get into his
mind a little bit still looks very good
for white so do we know why the
evaluation virus drops it it's hard to
say right it's hard to say it looks like
a very natural move White's Queen coming
towards kind of the where the action is
happening right now and we do see
stockfish giving its move suggestions
just below the player's cameras right
now and
it thinks that black should Retreat a
knight so that is the night on the edge
of the board we hate having nights on
the edge of the board step it back
towards the black king just keep it nice
and safe and that minimizes the damage
but there are other tempting moves I
would be inclined to think that it's
more Prague style to be kind of uh
he's a counter-attacking player we've
seen that throughout the tour he's his
style to kind of create threats be a bit
more direct so the second best move
according to the computer is for the
other Black Knight to jump into the
white position to the C2 Square hitting
the white rook in the corner hitting
white a white start Squad Bishop
looks very natural to me as well so I do
think we'll see one of the top two
computer moves for Prague because
they're both very natural right now
yeah it's uh it's a very tense position
now Prague is the one burning time on
the clock we could see a Time scramble
I think that will favor the younger
player here but uh Evancho is
calculating ahead so he's definitely got
a plan for the next few moves with this
queen jump yeah everything to play for
definitely everything to play for and
the position is heating up and you have
to say we aren't the only ones cheering
for the older generation oh Adam Genesis
doctor says go even joke art for you so
he even has his fans creating art
and uh well the move that you suggested
is on the board the night retreating
so stockfish's Top Choice but then again
the evaluation bar shot back up so I
mean it's that type of position it's
just so hard to calculate even the
computer needs some time to adjust maybe
there is a threat uh re-established on
white Central Pawn the one that did just
move Black's night was eyeing up that
pawn the black queen was eyeing up that
pawn as well so now this Black Knight is
kicked away from its perch
and where is it going to run to it could
just hide out in the center of the board
stunned to worry for the black queen
though she's running out of squares
and like Simon said just five six years
ago
uh the black king maybe is the one
actually in bigger danger as soon as
this Knight is kicked away the black
king doesn't have many
protectors left
the Pawns in front of it and White's
pieces are gravitating towards that
black king
can anything happen in this game can
anyone win it anyone can definitely win
this one but at the moment it looks like
white is the one with all the momentum
but as the time gets low you mentioned
this that um it's going to be Chucky we
fearful because prize got so much
experience now it's funny to say that
the answer
I mean who's got more experience perhaps
got more experience than the old Chucky
who's been around before Pride was born
but let me just say Prague has more
experience in in this kind of format in
his timely and that is such a it is just
true so if they get short time will
eventually be able to adapt
um okay but he's gone straight in I I
was wondering what would happen if the
The Rook now came up to Fork the queen
in the night but I guess there's some
traps right yeah what am I missing Rook
takes porn or something ridiculous
Knight takes porn
as Simon mentions this does look like a
killer a double attack hitting the black
queen also hitting the Black Knight in
the center but luckily for Prague there
is a check the Knight takes born check
hitting the king also hitting the rook
and when you capture Black's Queen can
escape and uh I mean it's still not that
bad for white but you have lost a pawn
in the process so it's close it's
hanging by a thread for black if we go
back to the current position
um if moving The Rook up doesn't work
maybe you just have to take your time
out to defend this Pawn that kind of
feels feels a bit you're doing not the
right things yeah just defending this
Pawn it's not bad but yeah uh kind of
hints out there maybe it's not great
either
what other moves could you look for
could you move the light Square Bishop
to you know block The Rook
um because then you're opening up the
Rooks to uh you know the rook in the
corner would love to join in the battle
and I always say you know when you're
when you're in the middle game this is a
good tip for everyone at home
um you want to get all your pieces in
the party like get all get all the guys
in the party you don't want someone on
their own at home you know they're gonna
be feeling sad aren't they get them all
in so you know buy that in life as well
exactly yeah get them all in the party
that's it and uh everyone yeah and you
might better double up the Rook saying
that little Rook could be the killer
that lonely Rook could be the killer
piece this re-establishes your idea
assignment as a threat this is now a
killer idea uh this double attack
bringing the route to G4 if black says
say does nothing then yeah one of the
black pieces will fall off the queen or
the knight in the center I don't even
see how black defends against this to be
honest can I show a cool line yeah it's
it's just I can't resist it's a
checkmating Chucky so if the night moves
you know because after all the night is
potentially under attack the bishop can
actually move two squares forward and
then if you're like no no no no no no no
the light Square Bishop that's under
attack moves to yeah and if the Knight
just moves back you know because after
all black is saying this repeat the
position I'm attacking the pawn again
black white will simply go no absolutely
not and capture the pawn with the queen
boom yeah and after Rook takes we've got
an old back rank I Checkmate oh I wasn't
even looking at that side of the board
that's like I was only looking at the
King on the other file you totally
switched my eyes over there I need to
look at the ceiling more like that I
need to stop getting obsessed with one
area
this Rook this lonely Rook because it
was kind of waiting outside the party it
was still queuing up but it's going to
get into the party and going to join the
attack yeah it's gonna be the start of
the party very nice line might well be
and he's played what we think is the
best move uh Chucky just bringing his
Bishop to this Square blocking the
blackrocks attack on this pawn and
suddenly Prague only with one minute now
how does he deal against this monster
threat and those track meeting ideas
that Ivanka showed oh I mean I think
he's a big favorite now eventually yeah
Black's pieces are just like especially
the Knight and queen which we said was
strong they're kind of had they're just
like really unsure themselves hanging
around there and that Rook move I I
don't know how you can stop it I mean
you if you had to play a move like H5
then you're just really like you know
what you might as well do
you might as well resign
when you can't do that never quit no
never quit I mean he's under a minute
though yeah well Chucky's only got one
minute 30. that is that's my main
concern for Chucky if he forgets about
his clock which as you said ivanka's
done before he's got a history of you
know looking at the ceiling too much and
forgetting about the clock and he has
played H5 and yeah okay he hasn't
resigned quite yet so it does look very
bad you've just weakened your own King
essentially yeah the king looks so weak
now and you could double up the Rooks a
very simple way to play now the white
Rook comes forwards one square getting
ready for the loner to come in swing
over
um maybe there's some other great ideas
here as well yeah it's just that look it
is kind of the Joker in the pack right
now just it could just completely
randomize the position uh if the ventric
panics and just has to make one or two
quick moves
this is his first time on the tour so
still adapting to that kind of online
format the time control
and gaining 10 seconds sounds like a lot
but yeah especially if you're getting
used to the uh kind of especially in
round one it can be tricky you'll move
Simon just that rook in the corner now
raring to go ready to join the action I
uh do like JD's tweet where he says that
they always root for pregnant except
when
check it's a 90s thing I like that one
to keep them coming with a hashtag chess
champs yeah he must have been world
number two when like 15 years before
Prague was born this is crazy yeah it's
crazy yeah thinking about that two games
that have finished with the winners
already in this first round you guys
it's Hans Neiman and Magnus Carlsen
currently those two are on top of the
table and the Julia's very generation
cup that is kind of strange taking in
account the recent chess drama but let's
see if Evancho joins them on top with
three points if he wins this game the
bar now saying
4.0 upon Advantage yeah it's looking
good for white I think okay it's the
most obvious move is probably the best
one here it's your move sign and just
swing that Rook across to the time the
time he's got to be careful I just I can
just see him forgetting about the clock
in seconds oh he's calculating too much
you can just played by Instinct oh
you've got you've got to look at the top
chunky so different see when you're
playing ten seconds this is playing over
the board
okay
oh
so relaxed but do you reckon he'd seen
the clock I think we're already I'm
still worried he hasn't seen the clock
I've just been worried sorry carry on
your van Gogh yeah but he's like leaning
back I mean this is different kind of
behavior normally we see everyone kind
of like primed they're leaning forward
their eager to strike and he's kind of
very detached and that's too chill 17
seconds yeah now Prague is the one low
on the clock on three seconds two
seconds he has to move
maybe a short delay here yeah he must
have moved yeah three seconds left you
made a move you had to make this move
the white Rooks were stacking up
attacking that pawn seven
see I think he might lose some time
with one second left he made that look
just one second oh we've seen all sorts
on the tour happen but we don't know
what to expect now
um Chucky yeah this bishop move looks
like a good one bringing another piece
towards him can he go Rook takes Pawn
this is the key I've always got another
one that's a bulldozer move look at that
pawn just uh opening up the position the
Prague is so calm Prague is a great
defender
um not only is a good counter-attacker
but he knows how to kind of just stay
alive in games and okay we saw an
exchange reports now White's Bishop
dropping back that's not a good sign he
just brought his Bishop forward now he's
lost a bit of time but still the black
king
out in the open now super weak
yeah if uh Chucky had five minutes here
it's a guaranteed white win but it's uh
seconds left on the clock for both
parties I think he has realized about
his clock though because he has speeded
up I I was just worried that he didn't
know that his time was getting short and
okay another move from Prague the pawn
coming forwards uh the Bishops must
start jumping into place soon surely but
it's such a complicated position you can
blunder even when you've got a winning
position so you just gotta calculate
very well here and okay is he going to
get to one second again no no I was
tempted to sacrifice material I was
wondering whether the hand would
irresistibly play this move I don't know
that's unexpected I thought he was going
to recapture his Knight so temporarily
white is actually a whole Rook down
but the attack now Prague
he can block this check this is why I
was surprised I think Chucky as well was
surprised by that move he lent back and
not for a good uh reason this time oh I
think the Tilt has started now the black
queen can just go and take the white
light Squad Bishop oh no look at his
face
he's just a rook down now no
compensation oh no heartbreak that's so
sad he was playing the perfect attack he
just I think he mixed up his move order
he found a great idea just got it uh
yeah I just didn't execute it in the
right way oh and now it's just over now
the white king is the one coming under
Fire yeah defended everything extra Rook
you can resign yeah I mean just uh
that's sad that's sad you know because
no and he resigns Ivan shook he was
about to win this game against Prague
but a blunder and huge